So,
all right,
so the individual as like culture,
like nature also has its negative
element.
You would call that the shadow.
You know,
and we're going to,
we're going to discuss the shadow in
some detail because one of the things
that you believed and he kind of got
this idea from nature was that when you
grow up and maybe as a consequence of
your temperament,
you tend to think that some of your
attributes are good and some of them are
negative,
you know,
so you make moral judgments about them
then.
Fair enough.
So you know,
you might think for the psychoanalysts,
the two elements of human being that
we're commonly regarded as negative from
a moral perspective or sexuality and
aggression and but yoga of notion is
that,
well,
you know,
you might be someone who's modest and
careful and never causes any conflict.
And then we might say,
well you're a well socialized person,
but you,
his point would be,
yeah,
but you've got no power,
you've got no power.
And so people are just going to roll
right over you.
So you better dive into that morass of
sexuality and aggression and pull out
those powers and integrate them into
your psyche so that you can use them
consciously.
Because without that,
you're harmless.
But you know,
I don't think that's a very good
ambition.
You know,
what do you want to be when you're 30
well,
I want to be harmless.
It's like,
you know,
really that's what you want to be.
It's like you might as well not even be
if that's your goal.
So,
so you know,
this dichotomy between the positive
individual and the negative individuals,
very,
very complex because what's positive and
what's negative is not obvious from the
beginning.
And arbitrary judgments don't help.
It's very difficult for a given
individual to look at themselves and
say,
well,
what is it about me that's actually
worth developing?
And I can tie this into some degree and
to big five theories.
So one of the big five characteristics
is
agreeableness safe.
And people tend to think of
agreeableness has a virtue,
which is a complete,
it's completely idiotic to think that
because every virtue has its vice.
But agreeable people are sympathetic and
empathetic.
And Compassionate and polite.
And those all sound like good things.
But they're also part of being an e
DePaul parent by the way.
But,
but anyways,
the problem with being agreeable is that
people take advantage of you and then
you get resentful.
So I'm sure there's a whole pile of you
in here that are agreeable and
resentful.
You know,
I'm sure you know who you are.
And one of the things I would mention,
and you should think about this cause
it'll help you a lot if you do it,
is that resentment is your best friend.
If something makes you resentful,
do not do it.
So,
or there's a more sophisticated rule,
which is if something makes you
resentful,
there's only two possibilities.
One is that you're sniffling and
immature and you won't adopt your
responsibilities and you're whining
about it.
The other is that you're being pushed
around and people are attempting to
enslave you.
So you want to eliminate the first
possibility,
right?
Got To think,
well,
am I just being immature and whining
about this?
Is it something that people are
reasonably demanding of me?
And if you think that through and maybe
you talked to some people about it and
you think,
no,
this isn't reasonable,
then the resentment is telling you act,
act because otherwise that's what you'll
be.
You'll end up 15 years,
especially if you're married or
something like that with 8,000 things
you're resentful about and then you know
you'll be in some kind of painful
divorce that lasts for 10 years.
So better to nip it in the bud.
If someone is after you to do something
and you don't feel like you're getting
proper regard or proper response or you
don't think it's fair,
it's like have some courage and get a
hold of your anger and use it.
It doesn't mean you're right,
but at least it means you can push the
person hard enough so they have to
engage in a dialogue with you and you
know this is,
these are necessary skills.
Like if you cannot do this,
you have to be able to say no to
negotiate.
You have to be able to say no.
So you always want to put yourself in a
position where you can do that.
That's part of being,
that's part of power.
And the other thing is do not let people
push you around because you'll get
pushed right into a corner and you'll
end up as a slave.
And that's because there's tyranny,
slavery,
or negotiation.
That's what you've got.